the secrets of Dumbledore definitely
took fan opinion into consideration the
relationship between Dumbledore and
Grindelwald was much more obvious this
time around because I was in love with
you plus it helps that mads Mickelson
suits the role of the villainous
Grindelwald much better than Johnny Depp
did everything I never had but this
movie was still a bit of a jungle Mass
when it came to plot with everything in
the movie revolving around a magical
MacGuffin that barely made any sense
it's a real shame because the first
Fantastic Beasts movie wasn't all that
bad and we would have liked to see this
franchise take off a little bit more but
as it stands we're afraid the Fantastic
Beasts series just isn't stacking up to
the rest of the Wizarding World